الأمين العام شكراً جزيلاً لك
أه أردت أن أسألك أولاً وقبل كل شيء ما إذا
كنت قد وافقت على بيان تم
الإدلاء به في الأيام القليلة الماضية بأن هذه
كانت أكبر كارثة في تاريخ
الناتو وأيضًا ما إذا كنت لا تعتقد أن
ما حدث  الأيام القليلة الماضية هي
بالفعل مسمار في نعش المادة 5
التي يمكن للحلفاء الدخول في معركة معًا ،
ولكن بمجرد عدم انسحابهم معًا نظرًا
لوجود مشكلة في تحالف الناتو ،
فهذه مأساة
أولاً وقبل كل شيء لشعب
أفغانستان.
على مدار 20 عامًا
،
نشرنا مئات الآلاف من قوات الناتو
، ودفع عدة آلاف الثمن النهائي
، وخدم مئات الآلاف
من الحلفاء غير الأمريكيين جنبًا إلى جنب مع
جنودنا في أفغانستان ودفع أكثر من
الآلاف الثمن النهائي ،
لذلك كان هذا حقًا ضخمًا  جهد
هذا التحالف
عندما وقعت الولايات المتحدة
اتفاقية مع طالبان في
فبراير 2020
أه بالطبع كان من الصعب جدًا
على الحلفاء الأوروبيين الاستمرار  يجب أن نبقى
لأننا كما أشرت إلى أننا ذهبنا إلى
أفغانستان كرد فعل
على هجوم على الولايات
المتحدة وعندما قررت الولايات المتحدة
إنهاء مهمتها العسكرية
هناك بالاتفاقية الموقعة في
فبراير 2020
، لم
يكن ذلك قابلاً للتطبيق  خيار عملي للحلفاء الآخرين
الأوروبيين المتحدين وكندا
للبقاء بدون الولايات
المتحدة.لا يزال الناتو تحالفًا قويًا
نفذ الناتو أكبر
تعزيز للدفاع الجماعي في
أوروبا منذ نهاية الحرب
الباردة وكانت رسالة واضحة جدًا
من الاجتماع  اليوم ، كل ما يحدث
في أفغانستان لا ينبغي أن يقوض
قدرتنا على حماية
الأراضي المتحالفة مع حلف شمال الأطلسي (الناتو) ،
وكانت تلك رسالة واضحة جدًا
من وزراء الخارجية اليوم.